today I present to you a video that took
way too long to make but on the bright
side its January which means new year's
resolutions fresh starts and an
optimistic outlook on the year ahead but
to you tubers it means sorta one thing
really low ad lights which means I get
to make pretty much anything I want
without any fear of consequences so I
figured it's been a hot second since I
did a drawing video and I've been seeing
Dragonball prop up in different styles
on Twitter here and there and that's
when I had an idea what if I drew Goku
in nine different styles some animates
so not so anime so I went to Twitter and
asked you guys to leave me suggestions
for different styles to draw mr. Sun
Wukong in and leave suggestions you most
certainly did hundreds in fact way too
many for me to draw so I took the ones
that interested me the most and these
are those styles first up Dragon Ball
the first time to kick things off will
be the classic Dragon Ball style you
know for comparison's sake when all is
said and done this is the only style
really I had any sort of substantial
experience in to be honest and I wasn't
happy with how it turned out at all but
it's not terrible and enough of my
insecurities this is pretty much the
process I follow I draw a basic outline
for the pose I want and I start drawing
over it until I'm sick of it being in
the background and I ultimately turn off
an eyeball the rest of it from there on
in at this point in the drawing I'm a
little anxious because I know the styles
that are coming up and I know that
they're going to be really hired for me
and to be honest they're Reedy tailed
and tough in general not to mention the
artist that perfected these styles are
legit some of my major inspirations when
it comes to art these include mr. Akira
Toriyama which I am trying and failing
to mimic right now which doesn't bode
well moving forward seeing as this is
the one that I have the most experience
in so how this is go to work is I'm
gonna pretty much show you guys the line
our process from beginning to end I'm
gonna snap my fingers and as if by magic
the entire piece will be colored alright
up to speed 1 2 3 here we go alright so
you guys might have some questions with
the color like why is his hair white
well in short because I thought I'd look
dope but it also is a way the Super
Saiyan form has been colored using a
limited color palette in the manga did I
take my own liberties with the color yes
absolutely but this is art there is no
wrong just happy mistakes
Goku's wonky eye is the happiest of all
the mistakes anyway what's next alrighty
I'm gonna level with you all ah this
style
it's my kryptonite everything is sharp
but not really and I honestly struggled
with it like a whole lot these eyes man
they make no sense to me then again no
eyes an anime really make sense but
these eyes really didn't make sense to
me but eventually I got the face done
and to be honest I was fairly surprised
with how well it turned out in the end
now UVO is the anime with the craziest
hair and about ten minutes into drawing
the hair I looked at my progress and
sauce that's definitely not crazy enough
and decided to scrap the entire thing
you see in ukyo the hair has to hit this
perfect balance of impossibly sharp and
being sort of electrocuted and so i went
back to the drawing board i don't know
if this worked out or not but it's
definitely a whole lot crazier and
definitely looks like he's being
electrocuted so that's a win for me
finally came the body and my god was
this difficult i couldn't find much
reference of ukyo characters shirtless
and my search history reflects the
damage of that reality it's sort of low
detailed but also kinda round I don't
know
the head with this one I was happy
enough with but the body gets a yikes
for me chief let's see it in some color
1 2 3 yeah kinda let's move on watch
words cannot express how excited I was
to attempt this art style after I saw
what have you guys suggested on Twitter
I loved Samurai Jack's art style and I
loved the show back in the day when it
was on Cartoon Network it's also unlike
anything I've ever attempted to draw
with its minimalistic approach and weird
shaped focus style you'd think this one
would be easier than drawing a regular
Dragonball art style and maybe it is for
some people but getting the face right
took ages for me because there are very
few components that make up the features
of this character if one thing is out of
place it has a massive knock-on effect
on the overall drawing it's for this
very reason I find drawing detailed
characters not necessarily easier but
more forgiving when it comes to the
final products reveal and this most
definitely is a minimalistic figuring
out the hair was probably the most
difficult aspect of this one
everything is very flat and I can't
really give anything definitely
not in the way that I would normally
with him eventually I settled on a
hairstyle I thought worked the body was
a bit of a challenge too but overall
this was a very fun style to attempt and
so with its fully drawn entered near
perfection it's time to see what it
looks like with some color 1 2 3 this
actually turned out way better than I
thought it would and it's one of my
favorites from this video but not my
absolute favorite next up this one was
honestly an absolute pain to draw and
it's probably the one I spend the most
time on reason being it took two
separate drawing sessions to get the
face to a standard I was happy with the
body was relatively easy but the hair in
the face was tough as all hell for me
to get the first draft of the face it
took me a little while but when I
finished it I really wasn't satisfied
with it so I took a break for like two
days and attempted it once again this
time with an idea to make him more like
all might and Lillian this sort of
worked I'm still not a hundred percent
happy with it but at least it's better
than it was woods before the body had
its own little hiccups here and there
but sincerely finding a face with this
that worked for me was a difficult
endeavor and finding a hairstyle that
worked for these guys is also proving to
be super hard too but again this one was
moderately satisfying to me when all was
said and done tie for some color one two
three yeah that looks a little better
six out of ten moving on oh I can't
believe you've done this okay so we're
at the halfway point and what better way
to mark this than with one of the most
talented artists in the world
Yusuke Murata the artist behind one
punch man manga one of the most gorgeous
and stunning mangas in circulation right
now Yusuke much like akira toriyama is
one of my major influences when it comes
to art and my god is he hard to
replicate everything about this style is
specific and measured sharp jagged lines
giving the impression of being messy but
everything serves a purpose this was
probably the most difficult overall
drawing I attempted with this challenge
the sheer volume of Lyons features and
proportions I had to tweak and alter
throughout is something I won't be soon
repeating however one aspect of drawing
this that made it much much easier was
that mr. Murata it seems is a massive
fan of Dragonball and has posted his own
fine art of Dragon Ball online on a
number of occasions and so for the first
time in this challenge I had very
specific reference material at my
disposal which definitely helped the
hair the face and the body it all had
tons and tons of detail and I was
exhausted by the time I finished up with
this one but once I finished it I was
actually pretty happy with how it turned
out time for some color one two three
this might be my favorite one so far
love me some wood punch man next studio
ghibli as well as the next two styles
are an absolute nightmare for me enjoy
for whatever reason they took me a super
long time and it was my very first time
drawing these styles the absolute
perfect storm for the worst drawing
experience Ghibli is first up here on
the chopping block I adore these films
I've seen them all a number of times and
for reference I decided to use ashitaka
from Princess Mononoke this is one of
those Styles much like the samurai jack
one that implements a somewhat
minimalistic less-is-more style and as a
result I struggled with this but in the
end I actually think it turned out
pretty well
additionally this is a style that is
much closer to real-world proportions
then something like Dragon Ball is so
the head is a little closer to regular
size and the body isn't nearly as small
as the original was but what I'm most
proud of with this drawing isn't the
face or the body which both took a
considerable amount of time mind you but
the hair I drew the heck out of this
hair and it took a long time to and I'm
genuinely really happy with the end
result here however once I finished I
quickly realized that he was too jacked
so while I was coloring I decided to
make him less swoll which hurt me a
little because it took a little time to
do all that kind of stuff but it made it
look much more like a studio ghibli
creation check it out
1 2 3 all in all I think it looks pretty
good and I'm happy with it next
the time has come Disney the company
that has it all the company that sort of
owns the distribution rights the Dragon
Ball in North America now which is
anyways this was another one of those
drawings that I hated my life during its
entire creation the fewer the lines in
these drawings that more difficult I
find things apparently and Disney is one
of those styles that you need to have
actual talent or skill in order to make
work but I'm willing to prove all the
haters wrong by taking an eternity to
get the face right this drawing was
cursed from the very beginning though
the hair in particular I struggled with
I don't even know if I like it to this
day
the body is another thing I had to pop
reference for as I had no idea how
Disney actually drew their bodies and
apparently every movie has its own
unique style
so let's see if any of you guys can
guess which movie I actually popped
reference for when drawing this Disney
Goku here's a hint
I use a different style for the hair the
face and the body I'll be reading the
comp to see if any of you guys can guess
correctly all three and now time for a
splash of color to put this Disney Goku
to bed one two three it's fine next I
[Music]
have never attempted or thought to draw
anything from JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
to be honest it looked like a ton of
work that I wasn't willing to put into
drawing but it was by far the most
requested style for me to attempt and so
here we go in truth this was the most
enjoyable experience I had drawing
throughout this entire video the style
actually suits my own shockingly well
specifically with the face from the eyes
to the nose to the mouth to the hair
everything has a boxy detail approach
that I genuinely had a ton of fun
drawing and it turned out pretty well -
if I say so myself the hair the face and
the body then when I was drawing this
dude I kept trying to find ways to make
him even more jacked than he already was
I mean he makes the Dragon Ball style
Goku look tight one thing I regretted
though while drawing this dude was that
he didn't have any clothes to draw in
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure is sort of both
the weird clothes and poses but it's not
like it matters the
this one was so much fun to draw and it
most definitely will not be my last time
drawing JoJo's Bizarre Adventure and now
time for a splash of color one two three
not bad time for the last draw
this was my favorite show before
Dragonball and it's only fitting it
rounds off this video and personally I
think it actually turned out pretty well
considering it's one of the only other
drawing styles I had any experience with
with the actual character itself I
didn't know if I wanted to go more Lance
the dragon trainer with the face or
Bruno with the face and ultimately I
thought Bruns suited the character more
Lance is more of a Vegeta type demeanor
isn't at least in terms of style the
hair was the only real challenge but I
sort of went for a lieutenants urge meet
Jolteon type spike situation the body
itself was super easy not too detailed
but the lines were still there in order
to help structure the pose and so let's
add some color one two three and Pat's
Goku drawn in nine different styles by
me totally not mark this was way way
harder and much more time-consuming than
I ever thought it would be I mean
it's January I'm supposed to be taking
it easy and this video took four times
longer to make than any of my other ones
and whatever if you want to see any of
the drawings to compare I'll be posting
them all on my Twitter at totally not
mark follow me if you want to see my
tweets I don't know I also put poles up
there so who knows you might be able to
influence a video I do in the future but
that'll do it for this week thank you so
much for watching and I'll see you all
in the next video
[Music]
you